[Music]
you have a line of sheets and
pillowcases my wife and I you what your
wife and yourself sleep like a king
right if you go to sleep like a king
calm they're made by the top people who
make the best bedding in the world and
they make sheets and pillowcases for
great hotels and we make the same thing
with our own touch Shawn designed a lot
of the products and you get them at very
reasonable cost
what about what's special about these
sheets is it 3 ply or 40 40 ply or I
mean I don't know anything about I don't
know from for flight six flight oh you
don't know wait a minute its thread
count put Ian over I lied down it feels
great mr. King that you don't have
adequate knowledge of your own product
oh no it's all how it feels okay have
you rolled around on each set of sheets
is that the many of them I have on the
pillows or the pillows feel wonderful
but they shipped out to the customers
just I wish you guys could experience it
it was real we can experience it Oh
through great expense no expense at all
we have your sheets and pillowcases here
and we're gonna test them the three of
us right now we're gonna lie on Larry
go
[Music]
Andy why don't you get on the other side
we'll put Larry in the mill well lucky
hey feel a lot feel that cool Wow okay I
love the stairs getting into bed that is
so slow to get here I get inside and
he's right yeah come on these feel
fantastic
these are amazing oh wow this is just
remember that old God this is the great
thing and now my final showbiz dream has
come true
Andy yes I love you
[Applause]
let's see if we can sell some here while
we're at it okay just put up a little
seer you go alright go to sleep like a
king calm yeah yeah alright a button
you'll thank me for it okay
okay I have a really weird job season
five of the multi Emmy nominated Larry
King now premieres July 25th
Honora TV and hulu Larry's collection
sleep wicked King this is there for now
let's sleep like a king calm
be right back
we'll be right back with porn historian
[Applause]
[Music]
you